auch gestern abend haben wieder tausende
gegen die korona maßnahmen protestiert
viele menschen fühlen sich offenbar von
der politik im stich gelassen sie fühlt
sich ausgeschlossen schließen sich aber
mit gewaltsamen protesten natürlich auch
selbst aus auch fdp chef christian
lindner gerät in diesem zusammenhang
jetzt in die kritik dass ungeimpfte vom
öffentlichen leben so gut wie
ausgeschlossen sind hätte nach seinen
versprechungen vor der wahl eigentlich
nicht passieren dürfen gemacht hatte sie
gegenüber passanten festgehalten in
einem video das derzeit auf twitter
tausendfach geteilt wird bevor wir mit
dem ehemaligen csu verkehrsminister
darüber reden der ziemlich wütend ist
schauen wir mal ran
weil ich als umgehend aktiviert werden
die fdp kommt ihr denn her
hier sind wir sind nicht auf uns und das
umgeben für mich diskriminiert ach ja ja
ja ja schon während andere von ihnen
gehört ja ich bin ich der funktion des
bv wesel fdp meine meinung ist er in
einer gesellschaft wo so viele geimpfte
kann der ungeimpfte sich höchstens
selbst bewerben deshalb sollen auch im
herbst ungeimpfte zb in die gaststätte
gehen können vielleicht mit der
voraussetzung eines negativen tests
denen sie aber nicht bezahlen müssen was
macht sie so wieder machen sagen sie
jetzt sagen sie das auch noch nach den
wahlen das sage ich vor den wahlen nach
den wahlen und 2017 haben sie gesehen
dass die fdp nach den wahlen sogar
bereit ist nein zu sagen zu einer
regierung wenn sie dann zu sagen brechen
müsste
ja die zu besagen brechende lindner ist
lean optio der lüge nennt also das hilft
der ehemalige bundesverkehrsminister
andreas scheuer den bundesfinanzminister
auf twitter vor drastische forderung an
die regierung über die wir jetzt mit ihm
persönlich sprechen wollen guten tag
herr scheuer
hallo grüße sie herr scheuer das schon
drastischer vorwurf liegen ob sie
bezichtigen ihn der lüge
er ist nicht ein wahlkampfversprechen
etwas ganz normales das nicht
eingehalten wird so machen es alle
parteien
sowie politik nicht wenn man
ihrer berichterstattung folgt und das
netz vergisst nichts es ist ja
bewegtbild ist es ja
lindner live und persönlich vor der wahl
und jetzt erleben wir die nokia nach der
wahl und wenn allein die debatten über
die impfpflicht wenn ich da die
einlassungen auch des fdp-politikers
kubicki sehe dann hat es mit einer
stringenten
anti-terror-politik einer koalition aber
vor allem auch einer bundesregierung in
der verantwortung als vizekanzler in der
christian lindner ist nichts zu tun naja
wir diskutieren über verschiedene
maßnahmen wird verschiedene
diskutieren über die impfpflicht und ich
sehe dass diese koalition nach ja nicht
also
nach einem monat der regierung im amt
nicht einmal mehr eine eigene mehrheit
hat da darf ich immer kurz vorlesen was
ihre ministerpräsidenten markus söder
gesagt hatte am 13 07 2011 21 keine
impfpflicht für lehrer auch keine
impfpflicht für schüler logischerweise
112 20 21 sagte er generell wäre es
natürlich gut wenn die impfpflicht
zumindest bei den wo der impfstoff schon
erprobtes ab 12 auch stattfinden würden
also sagen sie doch bitte nicht dass nur
die fdp versprechungen macht oder
aussagen trifft die anschließend nicht
mehr eingehalten werden
nein
das geht es ja gar nicht sondern wir
sind in einem prozess einer bekämpfung
der korona pandemie wo ich sehe dass die
ampel jetzt schon nach ein paar wochen
eine wahre lichtorgel ist also keine
stringente politik ja sie haben recht
wir verbessern uns über die wochen und
monate jeder weil er dazu lernt weil
jeder dazulernt ob in der koalition oder
in der opposition
aber was haben wir jetzt vor der wahl
von herrn lindner in der opposition
gehört war was ganz was anderes und
jetzt noch von anderen fdp politikern in
führender funktion herr kubicki ist
bundestags-vizepräsident ein hoher
repräsentanten fdp ich sage bringt
klarheit in die debatte um die
impfpflicht als bundesregierung als
koalition bestehend aus spd grüne und
fdp
und jeder ja das gebe ich für mich auch
zu muss in dieser pandemie dazulernen
ich hatte es für einen fehler gehalten
von vornherein die impfpflicht
auszuschließen aber das steht auf einem
online stern wir lernen in zwei jahren
jetzt dieser panne wie jeder politiker
dazu jetzt ist es aber so dass diese
regierung nicht eine gewissensfrage zur
abstimmung stellt über eine impfpflicht
sondern sie muss einen gesetzentwurf
vorlegen auf den warten wir alle zusagen
auch des kanzlers dass jetzt die debatte
um die impfpflicht beginnt der
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt wird und im märz
diese regelung dann gilt kann allein
zeit technisch nicht mehr eingehalten
werden und ich sage ihnen es ist eine
charakterfrage für mich
was der
bundeskanzler jetzt machen muss er wird
am morgen die regierungsbefragung haben
dass er diese im pflicht zur
vertrauensfrage macht dieser koalition
denn diese koalition muss eine mehrheit
aufstellen für einen gesetzentwurf und
für viele gesetzentwürfe nicht nur zur
krone und da erwarte ich bei so einer
weitreichenden entscheidung nicht nur
eine gewissensfrage sondern es ist eine
charakterfrage jetzt die vertrauensfrage
zu stellen um eine eigene mehrheit in
dieser koalition sicher zu stellen und
nicht auf die opposition zu hoffen dass
die mithilft einen gesetzentwurf der
neuen bundesregierung über die ziellinie
zu bringen herr steuer nach nicht einmal
zwei monaten wollen sie von kanzler
stolz dass er die vertrauensfrage
gestellt warum jetzt
ja weil als eine weitreichende
entscheidung ist ich glaube wir haben
so viel über maßnahmen in corona
debattiert die letzten eineinhalb bis
zwei jahre und jetzt kommen wir zu einer
entscheidenden wirklich entscheidenden
fragen wo jeder sich das habe ich auch
für meine partei und für mich persönlich
dazu lernen müssen immer wieder neu
verbessern musste in dieser pandemie
aber die impfpflicht ist natürlich eine
so weitreichende entscheidung dass man
nicht vom lavieren kann sondern ich
verlange dass der kanzler die
vertrauensfrage stellt um zu
dokumentieren dass diese ampel koalition
diese bundesregierung auch im parlament
eine eigene mehrheit aufstellt es
einfach laufen zu lassen und
orientierungs debatten zu führen da
halte ich das für zu wenig und der
tragweite nicht angepasst machen sie das
nur aus prinzip herrscher und sie
sprechen von charakterfragen oder geht
es ihnen tatsächlich um die sache oder
wollen sie einfach nur die regierung in
schwierigkeiten bringen denn es gibt ja
mittlerweile auch wieder zweifel neue
zweifel ob die impfpflicht tatsächlich
sinn macht angesichts der omicron
variante die sich verändert und
angesichts immer neuer varianten
da sind wir ja auch schon wieder ein
stück weit weg davon von diesem
kategorischen die impfpflicht muss da
sein trotzdem schießen sie jetzt ans
knie
ja es geht nicht sonst knie schießen
sondern es geht darum dass wir jetzt
nicht irgendwie eine neue regierung
haben und irgendwie ein paar parteien
eine koalition bilden es ist so in der
demokratie dass die mehrheit und das ist
einmal in der koalition jetzt
spd fdp und grüne eine eigene mehrheit
aufstellen müssen es ist ja auf einem
ganz anderen zettel
opposition mithilfe bei dieser frage ja
wir sind konstruktiv sehen sie sich die
frage um die den bundespräsidenten und
die wiederwahl von frank walter
steinmeier auch die union genauso gesagt
okay wir brauchen stabilität wir
brauchen keine neuerlichen debatten
frank walter steinmeier hat es soweit
ganz gut gemacht wir sind ok damit wenn
er die vertragsverlängerung bekommt aber
wenn ich mir die diskussionen in der
koalition anschauen der justizminister
buschmann ist gegen ein zentrales
register der kubicki ist gegen eine
impfpflicht und will sogar neuerlich
anträge mit anderen zusammen stellen aus
der fdp heraus frau berg werden auch
italien und verspricht was zur migration
freiburg und der cunard widersprechen
sich in nord stream 2 die eine sagt noch
vor der wahl nur zudem zwei darf
überhaupt nicht kommen der kühler sagt
als generalsekretär der spd also das
muss man abkoppeln vom ukraine konflikt
das ist wirklich jetzt schon nach ein
paar wochen nicht ampel sondern
lichtorgel wenn ich mir heute die
debatte um die
klimaschutzmaßnahmen anschaut die
energiepolitik die hier habe vorlegen
wird als sofortmaßnahmen höre ich schon
erste stimmen aus der fdp nachzulesen
heute in verschiedenen medien mann ist
dagegen ja so kann man bundesregierung
nicht machen er scheue aber trotzdem hat
mich auch diese regierung die berühmten
100 tage verdient
ja natürlich hat jeder eine
eingewöhnungszeit verdient aber diese
regierung ist auch gestartet um jeden zu
dokumentieren ab tag eins geht es
richtig los wir machen sofortprogramm
also ist er nicht ein einfall der
opposition dass er habe jetzt ein
klimaschutz sofortprogramm vorliegt
sondern seine eigene entscheidung also
muss opposition natürlich auch diese
maßnahmen kommentieren oder sie brauchen
ja auch eine
diskussionsgrundlage was wir anders
gemacht hätten als cdu und csu was wir
in der debatte nachfragen ist was hat
denn herr scholz für deutschland
verhandelt bei der eu taxonomie wenn
jetzt die kernkraft eingestuft wird in
der klimaneutralität dann möchte ich mal
wissen ist es jetzt die wahlkampfhilfe
für makro ist jetzt frankreich nach ein
paar wochen schon der sternekoch und
deutschland nur noch der kellner oder
was hat herr scholz denn in diesen
debatten für deutschland im nationalen
interesse heraus verhandelt ich möchte
das gerne wissen wie es in 2022 und
darüber hinaus mit einer neuen
bundesregierung weiter geht im
selbstverständnis deutschland mit
eigenen interessen aber natürlich
eingebunden in die eu solidarität
trotzdem bei der energiepolitik geht es
darum dass deutschland zum beispiel
unabhängig bleibt von den versorgungen
und da haben wir schon sehr viele fragen